but we do have an interesting story that
I want to I want to get controversial
for everybody so I hope you all are
ready this is from slate anti LGBTQ firm
tries to disqualify judge because he
won't let it miss gender trans kids the
story's not true it's not technically
it's not true so this is where things
start getting really weird have you read
a little bit about like the trans a
fleet stuff right yeah like basically
they're saying if you're biologically a
male of identify as female you can
compete against women right which I I
don't agree with here here's what
happened first at first they said woman
and man are words for gender which is a
social construct okay so if you if you
identify as a woman you can be a woman
because it's just a social construct
okay male and female are biology that's
what they said first a few years ago
okay so they were like we get it we get
it male means you were born with you
know XY and female means xx and then
there's intersex and things between over
time they've been erasing that entirely
and completely arguing that there's no
such thing as biological sex and it's
funny because I tell people this and
they say that's not true no one's saying
that
nicholas met a professor from toronto on
public access television in a debate
with jordan peterson said several years
ago it is not correct that there's a
such thing as biological sex normally I
like pulling it up to prove it to people
ya know I actually saw that
all right I've seen that so that's well
ran so here's the real story there's
biological males that have taken nor
home no hormones undergone no no you
know treatments yeah and they're racing
against biological females it's
ridiculous and they're winning every
time what a surprise and shattering
records mm-hmm sure so some young women
sued some young females sued in the case
the the attorney was on a conference
call with the judge and the judge said
you cannot my order is that you cannot
refer to these athletes the males as
male you must call them transgender
female think about what that means in a
court argument Your Honor I believe
these females should not be allowed to
compete against these females because
these females have a directed van
based on their female enemy well you'd
have to say these transgender females
against these females they're not
transgender females though but that's oh
I thought that the judges were wrong
okay so a male who is transgender right
to be woman a judge women means you are
trans gara may or not born a woman right
a male who is transgender right
biologically male okay who is
transgender okay
is now a woman to wants to be a woman
right or or identifies the potential A's
woman I don't know if they dint if is
okay the judge doesn't seem to
understand but more importantly whether
he understands or not I'm sure people
will argue what transgender female
really means anyway of course they will
so this is where like it gets really
really crazy now you have these articles
pop up this is nuts
like this article is an outright lie how
do we how do we actually deal with
protecting the civil rights of
individuals so these these women are
suing basically saying it's it's it's a
discrimination based on their biological
sex and the judge is saying you can't
say these words I don't know pardon me I
mean I've I follow
Ariella she was on the show and she's
she's a well-known lesbian who has a lot
of trans friends and I see her post
things to communicate with others and
ask questions to try to understand it
and so I'm following it and there's a
lot of trans people who don't agree with
this they're like yeah right it's not
fair where I'm trans and I don't agree
with this and it's like oh that's
interesting to know that not everyone
even the trans people think it's fair it
just makes me think it's not even the
trans people who are even fighting
anymore the company with karyn's it's
the people who are offended for others
like oh no that's offensive I should
fight for it no don't don't tell me that
I'm not that I don't care I'm gonna
fight for it anyway and letting me be
offended on your behalf yes exactly
that's what that's what really bothers
me the most about these people is like
that's what I think all this stuff is
when I was at Occupy Wall Street having
these white progressives tell me yeah
that I didn't understand racism I'm like
bro like do I gotta say it I'm gonna say
it my family's mixed-race how many times
I got it's funny cuz people bring up
they're like Tim said he's makes race
all-time I'm like yeah because you don't
get it man
like when I'm trying to communicate
effectively to a conservative I don't
say I don't say it at all they don't
care they literally don't there's not an
issue for them but if I'm trying to make
a video that will at least in some way
speak to some of these progressives and
liberals I have to say it otherwise
they're like what do you know you're
you're white guy not even that like half
the time they call me Hispanic
yeah they just it's it's it's insane how
bigoted these people have become while
claim like you know you know you know
the perfect the perfect the perfect
quote for this what is it um be careful
when fighting monsters lest you become
one for when you stare into the abyss
the abyss stares back okay that
perfectly explains these people they
started saying racism is bad we're gonna
fight for it and they became the overt
racists
yeah and now it's like but it's not just
about race it's about it's not the
bigotry right they said we're gonna
fight for the rights of minority groups
and they're literally taking away the
right of females to have a competitive
sport yeah
so all that all the the fight that women
have fought for for all these years for
everything else
sorry females yeah whatever it is it's
like yeah well if a guy feels like he
can do it better than you I'm sure I'm
gonna be a woman now and and when it's
not even that it's not even that right
so I'm sure it's it's a lot more
complicated than that but like yeah so
so I'll be as fair as I can I can be I'm
sure there are some some guys who are
like I'll just Sam a woman then I'll get
to compete hasn't that happened already
I mean I don't know not proven but it's
it's dangerous territory because then
you're you're you know claiming somebody
is this may be the reason the reason I'm
careful on this is because we don't even
need to go there okay if somebody is
born male okay and then says I want to
compete against females it's like I get
it but that's not fair
exactly it's not that is not equality it
isn't that is inequality you are taking
the rights away from them to have their
specific division now there's here's
what gets interesting and this is where
we get to go a little scientific not
really it's anecdotal oh great so the
Olympics will allow I believe the
Olympics in some capacity are going to
allow males to compete in the women's
divisions so long as their testosterone
levels are at a certain level are
like suppressed right okay pull up this
story pull up this story
lockdown Spurs 11 year old skateboarder
to make make history with first ten
eighty degree turn guy Curie lands holy
grail of skate skate skating while in
lockdown brazilians surpasses previous
record first set by Tony Hawk 11 years
old
brutal Tony Hawk was what summer t
thirty two thirty when he did that the
nine hundred yeah what'swhat's Tony yeah
yeah I think he was I think he was like
30 or maybe maybe he was in his late 20s
either way yeah my point is is obviously
he was born in 68 yeah dude II was like
32 Wow he was like 31 or 32 any language
day's tomorrow oh happy birthday Tony no
it's awesome I was watching his videos
on Instagram is amazing yeah it was
really great so now we're gonna get
controversial because I'm sure we're
gonna make much Beal angry here's my
question the first five four okay so for
those that don't aren't familiar with
skateboarding okay all right each time
the board rotates so that it's parallel
is 180 degrees so half turn full turn
360 one and a half is 540 to a 720 you
get it it's math Tony Hawk and I think
it was 1999 okay was it ninety nothing
sighs maybe he landed the first nine
hundred degree spin yeah
meaning he went up spun two and a half
times and came down and it took him
forever it was outside of the rules of
the event he'd already gone over but
everyone's like just do it just do it
man and it was so powerful that he got
all these crazy video game deals it
sparked the Tony Hawk franchise yeah he
made tons of money all skateboarding
immediately became like a multi-billion
dollar industry he revived the whole
sport and culture with one move than 900
and now Sunday 10th of May an 11 year
old boy just spun one more time than he
did here at like the height of 360 more
oh no no it was one out far so what this
kid did was he went fakie which means
you go backwards and he added a half
turn so it's it's incredible guy carries
skateboarding coming soon
this is are they yeah right a video game
series yeah so the first 10 ad we ever
saw was on the mega ramp
yeah it was me show me show some no no I
think it was was it Tom shark Mitchie
Brusco Mitchie was it yeah it's the
first 1080 so that was on a mega Rio
maybe he did the 1200 no no time was it
last year Tom shard to the 1260 I'm not
sure someone did a crazy I think it was
like they both did like crazy moves
that's why I always mix them up yeah
1260 yeah and it was a huge deal but
that's the mega ramp that's a really
really nice way Huns of speed this
little kid on a standard halfpipe that's
why it's record-breaking and it's break
the new record that's huge here's why it
bring us up in this context the first
female 540 I think was like 2008 or 2009
or something okay the first male 540 was
like the 70s no no the disparity in
skateboarding between men and women is
is the biggest for any sport I've ever
seen I don't know why don't ask me but
women definitely have been improving
dramatically and there's some really
really good female skaters well no you
you explained it on we talked about this
before and you explained it perfectly
it's the reason why is because there
isn't as many come like women to compete
against so when a woman goes out there
and they do like a kickflip to you know
500 on a rail it's like oh wow that's
the best trick done so they don't have
to kind of competition I have to raise
the bar too high to win but why would
you but but it's not just that right
here's the question I'm bringing up now
where I'm gonna get in trouble where any
other by YouTube sure why is it that a
prepubescent 11 year old boy
no puberty was able to pull off a
record-breaking historical move in the
skateboard in skateboarding history
where the where the 11 year old females
doing the same thing it's because
prenatal testosterone plays a huge role
so my question is if we're gonna allow
trans a fleet s-- transgender you know
people born male to compete in the
women's division no matter what is done
no matter if they get their testosterone
levels down they will have an advantage
period 100% like dude I've seen videos
of
your old boys like doing crazy things
yeah
I've competed I'm not gonna shout out
some of these people some of them are
pro now so I'll leave them to their to
their own I'm not gonna get them dragged
into this
but I've competed against some people
who are like much much younger than me
we absolutely destroyed me at my prime
like little kids just so good I'm like
this is nuts yeah I'm gonna don't man
these kids are just wiping the floor
with me in this contest but we don't see
the same thing from from from you know
eight-year-old girls or nine-year-old
girls there have been some like pretty
good moves from little kids yeah you
know younger females well I mean I have
to just bring in that the whole societal
impact of what a girl should be what
like girls dolls Barbies like the whole
thing like guys you know a boy sees
skateboarders and there's not that many
female skateboarders ooh there's Tony
Hawk is huge you know it's like you just
said it like 1999 skateboarding became a
billion-dollar industry you know so and
that's a guy sport predominantly so you
know growing up you know there's gonna
be more 11 year old skateboarders making
it you know boy skateboarders making
history you know over the girls so that
does come into play you know I think yes
right but I think I mean your point
remains though he did it before puberty
still broke a record that's insane in
history man this is a I agree like when
you look at Tony Hawk's career Monday
the 900 how big it was yeah it's 11 year
old kid just landed the 1080 on a
standard halfpipe yeah now he's you're
doing a contest I mean these kids are
skating their whole lives
this kid definitely was born on a
skateboard I'm totally to put money on
it and he's Brazilian too so it's like
you know Brazilians
for whatever reason Brazilians just like
the best capable they're really good at
skating ah Bob Burnquist yep he's brand
and Leticia Bufoni basically like the
best female shooter in the world using
yeah yeah she's better than like 99% of
dudes probably but then yeah so that's
like obviously female skateboarders can
be ridiculously good mm-hmm Leticia is
insanely good yeah she's really good but
what you know I bring this up because I
don't believe it's just society okay I
think it plays a role I think it's fair
like you know a younger girl is not
gonna see any like
you know super pup like well-known
females breaking records and I'd like
that probably as an impact yeah but
shouldn't it be at least I don't know if
they're skating together similar I don't
know man
IIIi really do feel like pre notes
prenatal testosterone plays a huge role
in this I agree because I've talked to
some scientists about it who have
brought that up and said that's the case
that even if you reduce your
testosterone levels you will still have
an advantage due to prenatal
testosterone levels yeah so now that
we're now that we're basically banned
from YouTube forever because they're
gonna claim and you know hate speech or
whatever nonsense gosh yeah I don't I
don't know how we navigate this man if
this is just us us I mean I have
transgender friends I'm not trying to
like oh well write it though just by
saying that what that you have friends
yeah that's a huge nono bro you can so
yeah you can are amazing people know
they agree with me you're not allowed to
say that okay that's like super
offensive so hue to the they to the left
whenever you having an argument if you
say well I have friends who are acts
they immediately snip that take that and
attack you for it well the reason why is
because I I've actually had
conversations with them so like I'm
going off my own experiences of what
they've told me so it's like I don't you
say the left and all these people it's
like who are they even to talk anyway
picture mobs on Twitter yeah exactly
that's so bring it on like I don't care
I I know what I know I know who you know
has told me their opinions on things and
yes it's it's weird that these companies
are more reactive to the left's mobs and
the rights mobs hmm you're right
whatever whatever you know you know you
know the way I explained it before it's
simple will you know here's what I said
like they're the ones that'll burn your
building down bingo bingo seriously yep
they're the scary mob there will never
be a moment where ben shapiro leads a
pitchfork mob of you know black ledum
asking people oh he's like Lola listen
you you you can't have a debate in this
building because it's is it defensive to
me and my people so gonna burn your
building down like never gonna happen
never in fact the worst case scenario
was he'd show up and be like I would I
would like to formally requested to bake
with you on your stage and it'll be like
hey that's awesome come on here yeah
alright the left your husband screams re
and throws a brick yeah you're never
gonna you're never gonna see like I mean
maybe there will be some you
there are some concern because nobody's
perfect but it's lopsided there's a very
few people on the right that would ever
try and pull some like that off the left
just lets it happen
they just re so so here's what here's
what I'll say about the left man yeah
regular liberal people are they gonna
stand up and defend our rights no no
you're gonna go through their own thing
they don't care not paying attention now
they're doing their own thing
conservatives are wired men they're on
they're active they're they're posting
memes they're making memes they're true
yep the left is just so here's what
happens the crazy the left have kin are
in control of the of the of the left
because the regular leftists just aren't
paying attention yeah that's what we get
man so I don't know I wanted to bring
this up because 1080 awesome it is
awesome and the other story was
ridiculous you wanna you want to
discredit all the people that are trying
to yell that he didn't actually do it
and he reverted out I've heard this bit
I was just total BS by the way I've
heard people argue that he did the 1080
uh-huh but he did a quick written ah get
out here he nailed it dude I think he
was past the 90 degree point like yeah
he might have like touched and on one
wheels back wheels came down and when he
had like 80 degrees left yeah exactly I
don't care but he rolled it out it
rolled through he landed it perfectly
because I can tell ya even I held it
it's it he took it low like who's going
for it man yeah so this kids basically
like 20 feet in the air and when you're
on a halfpipe you want to connect with
the top so you can transfer your energy
back to the ground otherwise you just
doom into the ground you know he took it
low he was like I'm not gonna land it
I'm not gonna put my feet down until I
stick it I guess I guess the advantage
of being 11 is he weighs like 50 pounds
that's true though won't it won't hurt
if he whips it
yeah he just probably didn't lose your
board and you slowly float to the ground
just slide on your knees yeah when
you're an adult like Tony Hawk is like
6-3 probably weighs like 200 pounds he's
a big dude yeah he's lanky as I take to
take 200 ever yeah but so any 20 slams
you know but they still stood he shreds
man had him in an eMac they did they're
constantly closing videos I love
watching his Instagram it's awesome yeah
yeah it's like I just follow
skateboarding in Spanish ah great nice
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to
catch the full show tune into this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you